global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the impact of the
pandemic in canada the fourth wave
pushing hospitals to the brink
particularly in alberta that province
leads the way by far with the highest
number of active cases across the
country but saskatchewan is in crisis as
well
saskatchewan has the highest rate of
deaths in the country in the last seven
days and the highest rate of new cases
of any province in the last week the
saskatchewan government still hasn't
officially asked ottawa to help with
record levels of covet 19. today the
province activated its emergency
operations center to lead its response
to the fourth wave but as conor
o'donovan reports it's not clear exactly
how that will help meet the most urgent
needs
is there an opportunity for us to even
look deeper within our province as to
are there you know ways to support
our frontline staff in particular those
that are working in our icu departments
thursday morning saskatchewan premier
scott mo announced a new command team
that he says will streamline emergency
response to the pandemic it includes
members from the health authority the
ministry of health and the saskatchewan
public safety agency which typically
responds to things like floods and
wildfires though it has helped move
personnel like nurses around the
province since the pandemic began this
is not a takeover this is just a
changing of a structure going into a
unified command
instead of us being a kind of a support
role the change-up comes during a week
in which hospitalization records were
broken four days in a row right now
there are a record 78 people in icu with
coveted 19 and 270 more in inpatient
care down from a record 280 on wednesday
the province has already slowed down
275 healthcare services to accommodate
up to 125 icu and 350 inpatients but
exactly how this new organization will
further increase capacity seems still to
be determined using the the
absolutely fantastic skills that my
staff have
we will be able to see benefits very
quickly and hopefully those will be
around those resourcing some
saskatchewan doctors meanwhile say it's
restrictions that are needed right now
not management restructuring in
particular limits on gathering sizes
those restrictions have worked we had
them in place in previous waves which
had helped us to perhaps come through
those waves
faster the healthcare system has
completely collapsed and all of our best
people the people that we need to look
after the sickest individuals in our
province
they're completely tapped out moe did
say thursday that nothing is off the
table right now including asking the
federal government for aid i think
that's a daily conversation that has
been occurring is you know you know what
can the federal government provide and
and at what point do we do we do we want
those provisions and and we may in the
next number of days make make that
formal request connor donovan global
news regina
newfoundland and labrador has launched
its vaccine passport system the new
mobile app will be available to download
free tomorrow and goes into effect
october 22nd proof of full vaccination
will come in the form of a qr code it
will be required to enter places like
bars restaurants and gyms but schools
retail shops and banks will be exempt
canada's small and medium-sized
businesses are waiting for the federal
government to announce an extension to
pandemic benefits wage and rent subsidy
programs are set to expire in three
weeks they can be extended until
mid-november but anything beyond that
will need parliamentary approval as mike
lacateur reports that's leaving some
businesses worried about the months
ahead
now we're
hello
on the other side of the room the
pandemic has changed how davinder kerr
runs her yoga center physical distancing
and provincial rules means she can only
have 50 percent of her clients in her
studio but she still has to pay 100
percent of salaries and rent it's hard
to continue to operate and generate
well
anywhere near the kind of revenue we
used to be able to generate pre-covet
kerr has leaned on federal benefits like
the wage and rent subsidy programs which
are set to expire in less than three
weeks
wednesday finance minister christopher
freeland said the government is
considering extending benefits
promising continued support for hard-hit
sectors tourism and events are some
examples
and so
we are
working on ways to ensure
that support is there for them
businesses need specifics to plan ahead
both the wage and rent subsidy programs
can be extended by cabinet until the end
of november but beyond that it would
require new legislation introduced
before parliament and there's no sense
of when this minority house of commons
is coming back we urge the prime
minister to recall parliament quickly so
we can pass fresh legislation to allow
for these subsidies and other supports
to be put in place to help get us
through what we expect to be very lean
months over the winter ndp leader
jagmeet singh says his party's support
for an extension has conditions the
support should go to people for sure and
to small businesses they've been the
hardest hit and we don't want to see
support continue for the large
corporations that have been able to get
through this time
with
in fact doing really well davinderker
has tried to remain zen through 19
months of lockdowns and capacity limits
but she needs more than promises to keep
her doors open it's great to say you
know hey
we've got your back well
please show me and until the benefits
are extended kerr has no choice but to
keep her business model
flexible mike lacouter global news
ottawa
is there an opportunity for us to even
look deeper within our province as to
are there you know ways to support
our frontline staff in particular those
that are working in our icu departments
thursday morning saskatchewan premier
scott mo announced a new command team
that he says will streamline emergency
response to the pandemic it includes
members from the health authority the
ministry of health and the saskatchewan
public safety agency which typically
responds to things like floods and
wildfires though it has helped move
personnel like nurses around the
province since the pandemic began this
is not a takeover this is just a
changing of a structure going into a
unified command instead of us being a
kind of a support role the change-up
comes during a week in which
hospitalization records were broken four
days in a row right now there are a
record 78 people in icu with covet 19
and 270 more in inpatient care down from
a record 280 on wednesday the province
has already slowed down 275 health care
services to accommodate up to 125 icu
and 350 inpatients but exactly how this
new organization will further increase
capacity seems still to be determined
using the the
absolutely fantastic skills that my
staff have
we will be able to see benefits very
quickly and hopefully those will be
around those resourcing some
saskatchewan doctors meanwhile say it's
restrictions that are needed right now
not management restructuring in
particular limits on gathering sizes
those restrictions have worked we had
them in place in previous waves which
had helped us to perhaps come through
those waves
faster the health care system is
completely collapsed and all of our best
people the people that we need to look
after the sickest individuals in our
province
they're completely tapped out mo did say
thursday that nothing is off the table
right now including asking the federal
government for aid i think that's a
daily conversation that has been
occurring is uh you know you know what
can the federal government provide and
uh and at what point do we do we do we
want those provisions and and we may in
the next number of days make make that
formal request connor donovan global
news regina
a former u.s army private who revealed
state secrets to wikileaks is fighting
to be allowed into canada chelsea
manning is appearing virtually in front
of the immigration and refugee board for
an admissibility hearing the canadian
government is seeking to permanently ban
her from entering the country on the
grounds of serious criminality chelsea
manning was convicted in the u.s of
violating the espionage act for leaking
hundreds of thousands of classified
documents to wikileaks
record-setting food prices coming up
what's fueling the rising cost of living
in canada
plus british businesses battle severe
staff shortages the ripple effect across
the uk
well there are more signs today the cost
of living is rising sharply world food
prices reached a 10-year peak in
september driven by the price of grains
and vegetable oils according to the food
price index which tracks the cost of the
most globally traded food commodities
food prices jumped more than 32 percent
last month from the same time last year
vegetable oils saw the steepest rise 60
percent higher than september of 2020.
grain prices soared by more than 27
percent
sugar meat and dairy prices also saw a
significant rise over the last year
on top of the higher food costs
canadians should brace for another bill
to get bigger this fall and winter and
gaviola has more on why heating costs
are set to rise as the mercury drops
as economies reopen around the world
demand for natural gas has come roaring
back but supply can't keep up we've been
caught off guard a little bit by the
pace of the global economic recovery now
the good news is that canada's situation
isn't as dire as what's happening in
europe where natural gas prices are
surging out of control and creating a
crisis but it's still cause for concern
wherever you live you can expect to pay
more fortis energy bc's biggest nat gas
distributor says the majority of its
customers could see monthly bills go up
by eight dollars in ontario enbridge
says most customers can expect an
increase between seven and forty four
dollars a year and manitoba hydro says
average annual bills will go up by
nearly nine percent for higher volume
customers closer to 20 percent and the
colder it gets this winter the harder
this will hit with demand raising
natural gas prices as with oil it
affects the cost of manufacturing and
transport which increases consumer costs
for well just about everything in
low-income households the ones already
living paycheck to paycheck are the
least able to cope these households are
faced with this trade-off between paying
down their energy bills
versus
paying for their necessities of life
such as
the food clothing and shelter economists
worry about stagflation the dreaded
combination of high inflation plus high
unemployment and slow economic growth
meaning higher energy prices could set
back economic recovery even as it boosts
the fortunes of some industries if
you're an energy producer
in the case of alberta newfoundland and
some other parts of canada um it is a
bit of a boon because it does help on
the production side a warming sector
that risks leaving some out in the cold
ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead brexit plus a pandemic has
britain struggling to fill labor demands
early morning confusion in pakistan a
5.9 magnitude earthquake rattling a
remote southwestern region of the
country
at least 23 people are dead another 200
have been injured with the most
seriously hurt being airlifted to larger
centers the quake bringing down mud
homes and collapsing a coal mine
officials expect the death toll to rise
once more help arrives
and some frayed nerves in tokyo a 5.9
magnitude earthquake shaking buildings
and forcing residents out into the
streets the late night quake also
knocked out power to more than 250 homes
and shut down a major railway station in
the city luckily no major damage has
been reported and no tsunami warnings
were issued
in the uk the army has been brought in
to help deliver fuel to desperate gas
stations chicken and beer are in short
supply and many supermarket shelves are
empty as redmond shannon reports the
supply chain issues come down to a labor
shortage only partially due to the
pandemic
they say the british love to join a
lineup and it's just as well these days
nothing we can do about it we just need
to wait
these gas shortages are not caused by
shortages of gas but by a lack of truck
drivers to deliver it even the british
army have been drafted in to help don't
know whose fault it is i really really
don't i just find it crazy that things
like this can happen i just think it's
ridiculous the uk's trucking industry
says it needs 100 000 new drivers but a
new temporary visa scheme saw just 127
applications from foreign workers
what that shows is the global
shortage there are worker shortages
across europe but the uk seems to be hit
the hardest bars and restaurants are
struggling to find staff too even farms
don't have the workers they need i'm
hearing of shortages as much as 40
percent on some farms and many growers
having to prioritize to decide
which crop to pick and which to leave
some pork farmers are culling pigs due
to a shortage of meat processors and
shoppers are seeing the consequences on
empty shelves the pandemic spurred
thousands of foreign low-paid workers to
leave experts say the end of free
movement into the uk after brexit is the
reason so few are returning we might
just end up frankly not producing as
many chicken parts as we used to
i don't quite know where it is going to
settle but you can't take a great chunk
of the less skilled workforce out and
think that you're going to carry on
doing exactly the same economist alan
winters says parts of prime minister
boris johnson's rushed eu trade deal to
get brexit done were short-sighted
johnson insists britain's economy needs
to be rebuilt but that shortages could
continue for some time redmond shannon
global news london
next the canadians who used pencil ink
and razor sharp wit to create honor
worthy cartoons
i i never thought i'd hear myself saying
this but you know it's an absolute honor
to be walked all over in hollywood so
um
daniel craig now has a star on the
hollywood walk of fame the bond actor's
name is emblazoned on the sidewalk at
7007 hollywood boulevard craig has been
playing the legendary british spy for
the past 15 years his fifth and final
bond film no time to die hits canadian
theaters tomorrow
also tomorrow canada post will be
releasing five new stamps paying tribute
to some of the nation's top editorial
cartoonists each stamp is
quintessentially canadian just like the
artists they're honoring and as mike
armstrong reports the collection is
drawing attention to the role this rare
craft plays in our culture
if you're doing something you love it
tends not to feel like work well terry
mosher's on five decades and counting
living that life as an editorial
cartoonist and figures he's been pretty
lucky there may be 15 people in canada
who make a living at it
there are more heart citizens than our
political cartoonists he has drawn more
than 14 000 cartoons now mosher is
better known under his pen name aslan
and longevity isn't what he should be
known for he's a legend in his field and
one of just five editorial cartoonists
canada post is honoring with their own
stamps there's brian gable of the globe
and mail the chronicle heralds bruce
mckinnon cell chaplain
and the late duncan macpherson of the
toronto star these guys are five of
canada's greatest editorial cartoonists
award-winning order of canada uh
recipients yeah these guys are are
beyond reproach now it isn't about
laughs a lot of times the topics they
tackle are touchy delicate even painful
what they seek to add to a newspaper is
satire and often a different way to look
at something everyone's talking about
you know reporters have to report the
actual news and commentators have to be
very careful we don't we draw what we
feel in our gut sometimes you actually
go further than people are comfortable
with i do
i have to want to keep putting my
editors on their toes
of course choosing cartoons for the
stamps was a challenge each of the
artists has decades of work and
thousands and thousands of pieces to
pick from they or their families
submitted about 25 each and a canada
post panel selected from those they're
little snapshots of canadian history
parts of the paper that stuck with
people they represent periods of time in
people's memories it's not an editorial
or a long but it was text or a story
it's either a photograph or a cartoon
that they remember
each of the cartoonists was given a copy
of their stamp aislins is of the 1972
summit series against russia it's a
piece he's proud of and he appreciates
the honor but he does say he sent canada
post a letter with a complaint it won't
fit on an envelope frank armstrong
global news montreal
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm sophie louis tonight's your
canada is the clouds rolling in the sky
above lac lavish alberta thanks for
watching and i hope you'll join us again
tomorrow
[Music]